thank you
all right the magic of the internet we
added a chair and a person we had a
local CEO at softleb who also happens to
be my brother-in-law and a new Floridian
a new Miami and a new American pretty
good not not bad for uh for a year uh
and the three of us sat down uh it's
about 15 16 months ago and we were had
this startup and basically you said to
us guys come here come here just
remember just make it happen and now
we've moved two companies to Florida
obviously locals here in Miami and uh
rumbles in Sarasota and uh well I guess
I'll start with you it's been pretty
sweet here in this Miami huh I don't
think it could have been better I mean I
think we had
um quite an exciting year since we sat
with you in cafesito talk just about a
year ago
so we had a lot right so personally I
think I mentioned it last time I moved a
few days before we did the cafesito talk
with you and now I have a baby that was
born here in Miami so he's a native man
I guess yes and a lot of things happened
to us so from a company perspective
after we talked we saw like a great goal
that happened to us the Miami magic the
Miami magic definitely happened to us
and at the end of 2021 we decided to
also match with a company called Rumble
yes which is a a video hosting and Cloud
platform that align with our ideology
and we started to work together and we
started to go even more and to get to
the last last month we actually went to
New York and we rang the bell together
with um
that's a lot of fun by the way I've done
it it's really fun I have to say that
was quite an experience for us huh wait
what's the mayor ring in a bell for it
for the Miami Miracle they actually
actually NASDAQ let me tell you
something about NASA I love NASDAQ other
than the fact that they're not in Miami
I love everything else about them but
they're actually very very proactive and
obviously support a lot of you know
content and tech companies and uh they
obviously knew what's going on and and
they've supported some of our
initiatives here when we've had Tech
month and all that stuff and so they
invited me up and they said hey the
Miami mayor's got to ring the bell you
know what I mean you got to talk about
this story so it was it was pretty cool
what are some of the things that you're
doing when companies either small tech
companies big tech companies just forget
Tech when companies move here what are
some of the things that you do to make
it friendly for them well we talked
about low taxes yeah and we talked about
rolling out the red carpet in the sense
that uh the attitude was different right
we want people to come here we want them
to succeed we believe that's
fundamentally American right so that's
that's the B part right what's our
attitude I think the C part is
substantive right like so we did some
Gorilla Marketing you know I put a
billboard out outside of Google and it
looked like a tweet that said uh taking
a moving to Miami DM right yeah and of
course I got thousands of DMS of people
Californians you know all the Google
employees but we did something I said
I've got to create an office in our
um in our city government to be able to
deal with this incoming right so I
created something called Venture Miami
and Venture Miami is essentially uh it
was originally Grant funded by all the
universities and everybody got involved
we want to give people concierge service
when they come here we want to make sure
that everything from getting a driver's
license to getting a permit uh anything
that they need to do finding a you know
connecting with the real estate
Community to make sure that they can
find a home as you've said we want to
make things as easy as possible to
onboard a company and then we want to
connect them with funders we want to
connect them with employee uh pipelines
we've done multiple
um sort of employee fairs job fairs so
that's sort of taking government to the
next step and being a facilitator you
know my view of government is it should
be limited and it should never take a
dollar more than it needs but in its
limited capacity it should facilitate
the growth of the private sector right
and and not getting away oftentimes
governments telling you no or we can't
do this and I often tell my people we're
the government of yes so that's what we
do what else should we ask this guy for
I mean here we are in Miami he wants
that there it is we're hiring yeah we
are definitely hiring and I have to say
being part of the ecosystem here in
Miami I I feel like there is a tech
ecosystem that is being built and we
talked about it a year ago and we start
to see that more and more great people
are coming here we have some great
creators that move to Miami and I think
we mentioned it last time we are
dedicated to create Miami a hub for
creators I love that and we want to
develop more and more platform and
that's why we are sitting here in this
beautiful Studio which we open in
Wynwood just recently wasn't easy for us
to get a spot here by the way it wasn't
easy we are very happy out of demand a
lot of demand yeah but we open it in
order to provide resource so we can help
the city of Miami to attract more
creators to come here and we want to
develop more events and basically to
provide more resource for creators to
succeed and keep being independent and I
think that Miami and Florida as a whole
stand for freedom and that's the reason
why we and ramboleta on the west coast
of Florida chose this state and this
great City of Miami to build our Venture
here well first of all I don't think you
could have put a better location because
there isn't a neighborhood in my opinion
in the United States and arguably one of
the best ones in the world where there's
more concentration of creativity yeah
you can feel it you can feel it yes look
at the walls of the buildings exactly
yeah and then the second second thing is
we did something really cool again and
this whole idea of government is not to
solve our problems but government can
help when the private sector leverages
right so we did a scholarship program
where the city only put half a million
dollars the private sector put five and
a half million dollars so eleven to one
laboratory right and that and that um
scholarship fund which was a venture
Miami scholarship fund was every child
in Miami every single one who is uh from
you know from a FAFSA perspective a Pell
Grant recipient so the neediest kids in
our community who wants to get a stem
degree University of Miami FIU Florida
Memorial or Miami-Dade College goes to
college for free now this is not about
college debt or waving college debt no
these are about people who have a Pell
Grant right they're getting some level
of government help and we're gonna just
we're the Gap we're the Gap funder of
this but we need stem creators people
that understand science technology math
right and also the creative economy like
you're talking about and the beauty of
it is you don't even need to really have
a college degree as you as we were
talking off offline you know some of the
most successful people in my
organization are people that are young
that they just understand this stuff in
ways that you know we could never fully
grasp yeah what do you uh if you had a
wish list of what the companies that are
coming here could bring Beyond
successful companies I mean is there
anything else that you want them to do
in terms of the community you know that
sort of thing well look I I think find
ways to create impact right obviously I
believe that the future economy is going
to be Creator economy I believe that
it's going to be experiential and I I
believe that it's going to be
technological so we're going all in on
crypto we're going all in on on on on on
the creative economy we're going all in
on artificial intelligence Quantum
Computing virtual reality cyber security
I mean this is going to define the
future right and I think education is a
big component of it because you can't
have you know Talent uh if you don't
develop that town so anything in the
educational space anything in the in the
mentoring space so you know we we love
to supply you with interns to learn
right and to see what you do which is
you're the talent to see what you do on
the production side and this
distribution side right like on your
Partnerships with Rumble understanding
the Dynamics about the economics of that
um and how you build a company like this
I think it would be incredibly
insightful for for our children you know
the young adults in our community
amazing so I first of all I think it's a
great opportunity for us to plug that we
are hiring we and ramble are hiring so
you can go to locust.com jobs to see the
jobs that we are offering in Miami I'm
going to plug that tube
we are looking for good people to join I
like what you said about inters as well
we think that the world has changed
completely I don't think that
necessarily you have to go to
universities to succeed and we see very
successful creators uh that are coming
from Miami and I'm going to plug another
creator that did something beautiful
here and why I think that Florida in
Miami is a different place for me here
in the United States so we also how it
can Ian which was uh devastating and
helped a lot of people and one of the
Creator which is a Miami based Creator
Steve will do it which you met him in
domestic as well uh donated a few RVs
and generators for families from Fort
Myers yesterday and to see how the
community is coming together also with
Miami and I saw the work that he was
doing and how everyone are coming
together that's what's unique about this
place so yes we are here at the end of
the day we have a business to run but we
want to help everyone and I think that's
something beautiful about what you're
creating here but but you know the other
thing is embracing Innovation is so
important because because you have
someone like Elon who's created the
starlink system now it's obviously being
used in Ukraine right but you think
about democratizing internet access in
Cuba and you think about forget about
that think about the US right we have so
we have an urban search and rescue team
when there's a hurricane like that we
only had one starting system because
it's new right and what we realized
everybody needed it yeah so I asked my
chief I said how many startling systems
could you yourself use just for your
Urban search and rescue team he said 15.
he had 50 people running on one system
because there was no nothing like it so
I think that embracing new technology is
creating solutions that can help people
in ways that we didn't even anticipate
how do we get Elon here what's he doing
in Texas
in the making so I
my pictures hopefully he buys Twitter
right and if he does
um My Hope Is that he brings Twitter
rebrands it and brings it here right
like open source you know the way he's
been talking about it right and I think
it's Miami is a great place for him to
to build a company like Twitter in the
way that he's talked about it a place
that Embraces freedom and and Liberty
um and that really um covets those
things because we've experienced the
opposite of it so that's my hope I'll
definitely be pitching him and hoping
that he does that
um he I've talked to him before about
the boring company which is the
underground uh company and and he said
look you know if you guys are an adopter
of it certainly that's something we
would look at him and we are you know in
uh discussions with them and doing some
some analysis to see whether it's
feasible in Miami given yeah probably
somewhat tricky here just because of
proximity to water it's it's actually
not so much water I'll tell you this so
in in Las Vegas which is the only city
right now where it's working it's
actually under the water table people
don't realize there is a water table in
Las Vegas and it's 18 feet here the
issue is the subsoil which is limestone
right in the density of the substool and
what kind of geotechnical issues that
creates but we're going through that
analysis and hopefully we'll have
something on that soon
well Mr Mayor I think I can speak for a
New York Refugee and an LA Refugee that
we are very happy to be here in Miami
continuing all this thank you thank you
guys thank you for believing in us and
for for being evangelist of what's
Happening Here Freedom man it is that's
it simple if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about tech instead of non-stop yelling
check out our Tech playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell